here's what I did before making this
video I was at home watching kpop videos
when suddenly I thought useless and
pathetic because I just spent two hours
watching 4 girls say I needed some sort
of confirmation that I was still wanted
and loved in this world so I called my
mom she didn't pick up she never does so
I need a new way to feel validated and
my next best thing my data science
skills I needed to feel wanted so I
refat my resume
brushed my hair and applied to all these
data science analytics positions I
whispered to myself tell me you want me
I quickly learned that takes more than
20 minutes to get an interview so I
unbrushed my hair took my pants off and
went to bed soon the interview started
flowing in one phone call two phone call
three phone call rejection you win some
you lose some
I started getting on-site interviews one
on site two on site three on site at
every interview I whispered to them tell
me you want me some did some didn't but
I had what I need I'm validated and here
is what I learned from all these
interviews
[Music]
pull up so for the technical interview
this is basically just a simple SQL or
sequel question or it can also be a
simple coding question like Python or
something and the reason why they ask
you this question is to make sure that
you know how to write queries because
you're gonna be doing a lot of that on
the job and also if you can work with a
simple program if you could write simple
programs nothing too complicated now not
gonna lie this part of the interview or
this interview is probably going to be
the easiest out of the data science
analytics position so let's see if you
can solve one of these questions here's
an example so here you have a table
called publisher info that has all the
information about a publisher and the
videos they publish and then you have
the consumption info where you have all
the information of user consuming a
single video so two questions one how
many minutes worth of video does an
average publisher have two how many
publishers have at least one user who
watched their videos I'll give you ten
seconds to finish it DDT
so here's the answer obviously in a real
interview there would be more follow-up
questions since it's an hour long but
let me show you how I studied for it I
locked myself in a room and open
cracking the coding interview and finish
all the questions until chapter 5 or
until I feel like puking after that I go
to all these websites to practice sequel
questions and of course I go on
Glassdoor comm to see if we could find
it in juicy unique tech questions
the math interview are sometimes they
call it the quantitative interview this
one is quite simple also because they
just ask you some simple probability
questions or some simple descriptive
statistics question so here's an example
geomatics an STD test and the test is
advertised as being 99% accurate if you
have the SCD your test positive 99% of
the time if you don't have the STD you
will test negative 99% of the time if 1%
of all people have this STD and Joanne
test positive what is the probability
that Joma has this disease I'll give you
a few seconds to answer this Russian
tic-tock tic-tock tic-tock tic-tock
tic-tock tic-tock tic-tock thing so the
answer is zero because you have to get
late to get an STD anyways the right
answer is 50% and you have to use Bayes
theorem so if you went to college and
you listened during your freshman year
these concepts should be pretty familiar
to you but then again that's only if you
remember them so here's a list of things
that they would ask you about so like
conditional probabilities Bayes theorem
binomial distribution normal
distribution descriptive statistics and
like understanding the law of large
numbers central limit theorem and linear
regressions so if you understand these
concepts that's pretty good and you
should be fine and then for me I wasn't
fine because I didn't listen so what I
did to study for that I went back to my
old textbooks read some of these
chapters and then refresh my memory and
then also I did some practice questions
especially for probabilities because
sometimes it's a little bit tricky it's
almost like a brain teaser so you just
got practice just like quoting the
product interview now this is a little
bit subjective but it's important
get right they will ask you a
hypothetical product and how you improve
it and then they will also ask you what
metrics would you track to measure its
success also they're going to give you
situations where there are trade-offs
between metrics and you have to argue
which one is best for the product it's
not always black and white we just want
to know how well do you work with data
in the products perspective so it's kind
of hard to give you an example of a
question because usually it's like a
back and forth and a conversation so
here's an example of what the interview
will look like alright so as you know
not vine is a platform where users can
share 6.1 looping videos as seen in the
startup series
and it's basically a feat of content you
follow now imagine we are considering
launching a share button where you can
share someone else's video and it will
show to your followers how would you
evaluate this change what metrics do you
expect to change and how will you decide
to launch it or not hmm well we can do
an experiment roll out to only a few
publishers first and then a be tested so
for some users they see it and for some
they don't see the shared post that way
we can see the difference in consumer
behavior for example inventory will
probably go up because of that we will
see if it increases video watch time per
person and if it increases retention
from users with this feature we also
have to make sure it doesn't cannibalize
the original content so even if they
have more video impressions we want to
see if the view per impressions didn't
decrease too much which can mean they
don't care about the shared videos we
can also run surveys to survey them if
they enjoy watching this shared content
so so product questions are like that
but usually with more follow-ups and
more deep dives but you get the gist so
obviously this is a generalizations of
all the data science interviews I've had
some are harder some are easier but if
you are able to answer these question
your chance of getting a data science
job is higher with statistical
significance than if you weren't able to
answer these questions by the way this
video was sponsored by brilliant org
which is kind of cool because I actually
used brilliant
or when I was applying to my untitled
large company since the company gave me
links to help me prepare for my
interview and one of the links that they
gave me is a bunch of combinatorics
questions
aka probability questions on brilliant
org it really helped me on the math part
of the interview because I was killing
the probability questions I actually
find it really fun to crank out these
questions it makes me feel good about
myself and keeps me sharp and they're
good brain teasers for interviews
especially for data science of quantum
very good supplement to my interview
preps so highly recommended also if
you're in school you can supplement your
learning by using this website because
there's a wide variety of topics which
is pre-built because I love the UI on
the website and it makes studying so
much more fun with their quizzes if
you're interested there's a link in the
description down below best of all you
can get 20% off their premium
subscription so you two you can kill it
at the interview for the large on type
of company alright I hope you enjoyed
this video or I gotta go now
cuz I'll have to figure out how to make
food because my roommates are gone
I've been eating Cheetos for like the
past two days but yeah
[Music]
almost